FEMALE SPEAKER: Y'all give
it up for Eric Roberson.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERING]
[MUSIC - ERIC ROBERSON,
"DON'T CHANGE FOR ME"]
ERIC ROBERSON: This is always
an important part for house
music, this part right here.
[MUSIC - ERIC ROBERSON,
"DON'T CHANGE FOR ME"]
ERIC ROBERSON: Of course,
I wasn't recording that.
So let's do it now.
Here we go.
[MUSIC - ERIC ROBERSON,
"DON'T CHANGE FOR ME"]
ERIC ROBERSON: Let's do it.
[MUSIC - ERIC ROBERSON,
"DON'T CHANGE FOR ME"]
ERIC ROBERSON: I hear
you singing, girl.
Come on.
[MUSIC - ERIC ROBERSON,
"DON'T CHANGE FOR ME"]
[APPLAUSE]
ERIC ROBERSON: You
can unmute it.
[LAUGHTER]
ERIC ROBERSON: How many of you
ever dealt with somebody you
shouldn't have been
dealing with.
Why did you look at her?
He like turned and
[CLAPS HANDS].
What was that?
I mean, first of all, she's
sitting like high, and you're
sitting low, which makes it
a very awkward situation.
But I want to ask
the question.
He shifted his [CLAPS HANDS].
[LAUGHTER]
ERIC ROBERSON: But you
can start that.
You can start that.
But if you were in that
situation, I'm going to
dedicate it to this guy
right here who--
[LAUGHTER].
What's your name, man?
What's your name?
AUDIENCE: Howard.
ERIC ROBERSON: Howard.
I went to Howard.
So, you know.
[CHEERS]
ERIC ROBERSON: Yes, yes.
You went to Howard as well?
in.
Your name is Howard.
She went to Howard.
Are you guys together?
Are you guys?
Mmmm.
Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
ERIC ROBERSON: I understand.
Should have been dealing.
OK.
It's OK.
It's cool.
It's only on tape.
Are you single?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ERIC ROBERSON: Wow!
Howard.
Howard, you thinking, if I bring
her, but sit on another
level, I might get
away with this.
What about you?
What's your name, sweetheart?
What's your name.
AUDIENCE: Karen.
ERIC ROBERSON: All right,
Karen, are you single?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ERIC ROBERSON: OK, so
Karen is single.
Howard is ha ha ha ha, a ha.
OK, all right.
Howard and Karen.
There are no accidents.
I want to dedicate this song
to Howard and Carol.
Karen.
Karen or Carol?
My goal is by the end of this
song is Howard is licking
Karen's face.
That's my goal.
[MUSIC - ERIC ROBERSON,
"DEALING"]
ERIC ROBERSON: You
know this part.
Why don't you sing this part?
[LAUGHTER]
[MUSIC - ERIC ROBERSON,
"DEALING"]
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERS]
ERIC ROBERSON: Thank you.
Thank you.
I want to do something
special.
We're live on the air, and we
have a lot of companies here.
And I want to do something
special.
I'm going to write a song, if
possible, right this very
second, on the spot, me and
my good friend Ian.
But I want to include
you guys as well.
And see, this is how special
it's going to be.
Check this out.
The song is going to be such a
hit, that American Express is
going to pay for it.
And they're going to put
it on a commercial.
We're going to make
a ton of money.
And I'm going to share the
proceeds with everyone in the
room, because I'm a
fair kind of guy.
All right?
But there's a simple thing.
It's a simple rule you
need to follow.
I need subjects--
words, thoughts, whatever's
from the crowd.
I need whatever.
But before you yell something
out, let the word you yell out
be a fun word.
Do not give me a boring--
I'm trying to impress
American Express.
Do not give me a boring
whack simple word.
Don't give me love or peace
or fate or intimacy or
anything like that.
I need good words, like
toenail clippings or
something like that.
The better the song, the
better our chances that
American Express will
pay for this.
If you decide to still give
me a simple word--
trust me, I have a cordless
microphone--
I'm going to turn the
cameras off, and I
will throw this mic.
[LAUGHTER]
ERIC ROBERSON: As hard and as
accurate as I can into your
chest cavity.
OK?
Any words?
AUDIENCE: Lilacs.
ERIC ROBERSON: You
said lilacs?
Lilacs.
Lilacs, is that a flower?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ERIC ROBERSON: Wow.
I can imagine what's
on your mind.
Lilacs.
What color is a lilac,
just so I know?
AUDIENCE: Purple.
ERIC ROBERSON: Purple.
Thank you very much.
What did you said over here?
What?
AUDIENCE: I didn't
say anything.
ERIC ROBERSON: What
did he say?
I'm not going to use it.
I just need to know
what he said.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ERIC ROBERSON: Excellent.
Look at you.
Thank you.
Is that why you're bent over?
OK, I got you.
I got you.
It's cool.
He's like ugh.
[INAUDIBLE].
You're disqualified.
Anything over here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
ERIC ROBERSON: Brazil.
I love it.
I'll tell you a quick story.
My wife went to Brazil.
My wife went to Wharton, and
they did a school trip.
And she came back, and I was at
the airport to greet her,
like happy.
And as soon as she got off the
plane, the first thing she
said to me was, you're
never going there.
[LAUGHTER]
ERIC ROBERSON: That's
a true story.
It's a true story.
So I'm going to sing this
song in honor of my
absence from Brazil.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: Google.
ERIC ROBERSON: Thank you.
Cha ching.
We're going to get that money.
[LAUGHTER]
ERIC ROBERSON: What's that?
Roller coaster.
OK, I think we're good.
Are we good?
I think we're good.
Listen, I'm going to
write this down.
And I usually remember this,
but I'm going to write it
down, because I need you
guys to remember it.
So we have roller coaster.
I'm just writing roller, because
we don't have time.
What was the other ones?
I forgot that fast.
Google.
Lilac.
How do you spell lilac?
What is that?
Oh, lord.
Just the one young lady
with the chain.
What's that?
AUDIENCE: L-I-L-A-C-S.
ERIC ROBERSON: You won
your spelling bee.
Oh, plural.
You want to do lilacs.
OK, got you.
Got you.
And Brazil.
OK.
Are you ready for the song?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
ERIC ROBERSON: OK.
OK.
What was your word?
Julie, I'm going to
take your word.
What was your word?
AUDIENCE: Investment.
ERIC ROBERSON: Is investment?
All right.
So corporate investment.
[LAUGHTER]
ERIC ROBERSON: We are in a
room full of lawyers and
entrepreneurs.
CDs are only $10.
You can make the investment.
[LAUGHTER]
ERIC ROBERSON: OK, OK.
I apologize.
I apologize, Ryan,
for my silliness.
Someone slipped something
in my tea, I think.
OK, so we have roller coaster,
Google, lilacs--
plural--
Brazil, and investment.
Where's the camera at?
I just want to make sure
that they see this.
OK, all right.
And Ian's going to create
the music right now
on the spot as well.
So he's going to get some
publishing as well.
So you can start it wherever
you feel--
if you want, I'll throw even
a beat to it as well.
But we'll let you start first.
[MUSIC - ERIC ROBERSON]
ERIC ROBERSON: Let's
go to Brazil.
[MUSIC - ERIC ROBERSON]
ERIC ROBERSON: Roller coaster,
Google, lilacs, Brazil, and
investment.
I might even throw
your Ex-Lax in.
I might do it.
[MUSIC - ERIC ROBERSON]
ERIC ROBERSON: [SINGING]
Let me tell you about a story
when I was laying on my sofa.
[INAUDIBLE] girl had my
heart go up and down
like a roller coaster.
And I don't mean to say like
that's a good thing.
But you gave me the words so
there's a song I need to sing.
I'm from Jersey.
She was from Brazil.
It's hot there.
I live where it's chill.
I tried to say I love you.
I offered her daffodils.
She said that's whack.
So I brought her some lilacs.
And she let me in.
And I entered.
It was lovely, most
of it I remember.
See, I thought this girl
was heaven sent.
From that point, I was ready
to make an investment.
I went to go buy your ring.
I even knew the size.
She showed me what she liked.
I checked out the
price on Google.
That's expensive.
Wish she was frugal.
So I bought it anyway.
I ignored the danger signs.
Went with my heart
and not my mind.
So I got on my knee while she
was laying on my sofa.
Won't you be with me
for my ride through
life's roller coaster?
And she said, yes.
Softly laid down here, then
dropped down on my chest.
I replied by putting my hand
right on her thigh.
Get your mind out the gutter.
So we thought about the wedding
plans and everything
and how we would have
wine that was chill.
And we would walk, and I would
carry her through the house,
hold her up, and we would have
a honeymoon out in Brazil.
And I mean, she would walk
down, and the flower girl
would be looking beautiful
throwing purple lilacs.
Until I found out that the price
of the wedding put my
American Express to the max.
What I thought was heaven sent
has turned into a bad
investment.
Now I'm looking at all
my money has went.
Seems like all of my money
is really spent.
Next time, I'll find someone
frugal so I won't have to find
out about bankruptcy
in Google.
Hopefully, next time I'll
find someone frugal.
Maybe I'll find a dating site.
Let me type it in on Google--
singleblackman.com,
singlewoman.com.
That's [INAUDIBLE]
pause.
What was that?
I turned to the wrong website.
I think.
I'll not go back.
Had a bald-headed guy
in a speedo and in
his mouth was a lilac.
So this moral of the story,
before I am done, you need to
really find who you invest in.
It's not all about just fun.
Because this young lady
may take your heart
and not give it back.
And your heart will feel
like you just took a
whole bunch of Ex-Lax.
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERS]
ERIC ROBERSON: Thank you very
much, ladies and gentleman.
This song is on the new album,
which is called "Mr. Nice
Guy." And you can start it,
because I want to talk a
little while you
play this part.
But the song was inspired
by my grandfather, an
amazing wise man.
And he lived in North
Carolina in a
little town called Stokes.
And in that little town
called Stokes, there
was a little house.
And in that little
house was a man.
And that man was my grandfather
who would have
these amazing talks in
front of the house.
And one time, he said,
Eric, I'm not
into hugging in church.
Now, he was a pastor in a little
church down the street
on a dirt road.
He said, Eric, I'm not into
hugging in church.
So I sat up and said, why not?
He said, because I'm a man.
And if you touch me, I'm going
to feel something.
Now, Lou Ray?
That Lou Ray in that kitchen
there, oh, I love Lou Ray.
I love Lou Ray enough to
understand that I'm a man.
And so Eric, sometimes it's just
better to just shake a
hand and walk away.
Because it helps [INAUDIBLE].
I'm going to dedicate this song
to that one particular
woman in this room who
thought she had a
shot with me tonight.
[LAUGHTER]
ERIC ROBERSON: Oh,
I apologize.
I can hear somebody in
the back going, damn.
I apologize.
I apologize for my silliness.
OK.
[INAUDIBLE].
[MUSIC - ERIC ROBERSON,
"SHAKE HER HAND"]
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERS]
[MUSIC - ERIC ROBERSON,
"COULDN'T HEAR ME"]
[APPLAUSE AND CHEERS]
ERIC ROBERSON: God bless you.
Once again, Ian McColly.
My name's Eric Roberson.
Thank you very much.
I appreciate everybody
for all the love.
We hanging out, so I hope to
meet everyone of you guys.
Take care.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
RYAN VUKELICH: So Eric, thanks
so much for being here at
Google today.
ERIC ROBERSON: Ryan, thank
you very much.
RYAN VUKELICH: Second time--
ERIC ROBERSON: Yes.
RYAN VUKELICH: --is
a charm, I hear.
ERIC ROBERSON: I'm getting
more and more
familiar with the stage.
And I handed in my application
to Google, because I love the
building so much.
Hopefully, just waiting
for a call back.
I knew I should have gotten
rid of that iPhone.
It's another story.
I'm getting an Android
any second now.
RYAN VUKELICH: Cool.
That will probably put
it over the top.
Just kidding.
But yeah, just wanted to talk.
We're celebrating Black
History Month tonight.
And I'm so happy you're here
hosting the event.
ERIC ROBERSON: Thank you.
RYAN VUKELICH: I head you were
Mr. Black Teen Universe.
ERIC ROBERSON: Mr. Black
Teenage World was
actually the title.
RYAN VUKELICH: World.
So the whole world, not just
the US, but everyone.
ERIC ROBERSON: It included like
one person from overseas
who was like, we've got it.
We've got the world.
But yeah, I was 16-years-old,
man.
And my sister, who I give a
lot of credit for me even
doing art in any form
or fashion,
because she was so talented.
She was in a lot of pageants
that my mom and father were
putting her in.
And my mom found a pageant
for teenage boys.
RYAN VUKELICH: Cool.
ERIC ROBERSON: And I got up
there and embarrassed myself
and won the state.
And then I won the national.
And it gave me a full
scholarship to Howard
University, so that was a great
part that came out of it
also, as well.
RYAN VUKELICH: Yeah, I'm sure
that couldn't have hurt your
image of yourself.
ERIC ROBERSON: Right,
right, right.
RYAN VUKELICH: Mr. World.
ERIC ROBERSON: Mr.
Teenage World.
RYAN VUKELICH: But in
seriousness, can you explain
how did that affect your
trajectory from there?
Was that a big moment, or was
it just something you did?
RYAN VUKELICH: It was
a huge moment.
It was a huge moment.
I think one, I've always said
that I was somehow going to go
to college on a scholarship,
whether it was playing
football or doing something.
And at the same time, going into
my junior year where at
that point I was drawing and
designing clothes, doing
theater, making music,
skateboarding, BMXing.
I was just all over the place in
everything I wanted to do.
So to gain a scholarship by
pretty much singing for the
most part--
I had to do other things
in the pageant--
it really said, Mom and Dad, I
think I'm not going to be a
political science major.
I think I want to try--
there wasn't an R&B major.
There wasn't a, can I major
in being Al B Sure!
I couldn't do it.
So I grew up doing theater.
So I went as a musical
theater major, man.
And it was going to Howard.
And it was one of the best
decisions ever in my life.
RYAN VUKELICH: Can you talk
about Howard and the role of
historically black colleges and
universities and also of
Black History Month?
ERIC ROBERSON: Indeed.
You're walking down hallways
that Donny
Hathaway hummed down.
You're going into practice
rooms that Roberta
Flack played in.
You're standing on a stage
reading a monologue that
Phylicia Rashad read
a monologue on.
Just a history of it.
And I learned very early
on to be very prepared.
Because at any second, Q-Tip
from a Tribe Called Quest or
Bill Cosby or Muhammad Ali will
walk down the hallway or
across the yard.
But at the same time, my friends
were getting signed.
If anybody remembers-- (SINGS)
and if I ever--
the group Shai, "Fall
in Love" song.
We were friends.
They were our buddies
at Howard.
And they handed their
record to a DJ.
And two weeks later, they're
on "Arsenio Hall." And five
weeks later, they had finished
the album in a week, handed in
the album, sold three
million copies.
And I handed them my demo
and said just hand it
to somebody in LA.
Before I knew it, I
was flying there.
And in my sophomore year,
I got a record deal.
And so it was just a very
working environment.
One of my professors, the late,
great amazing Al Freeman
who played Elijah Muhammad in
the "Malcolm X" movie was one
of my teachers.
And he shot it while teaching.
So I'm like, I'm going to LA
next week to try to meet with
Warner Brothers for
a record deal.
Like how can he be like no,
stay here and work on your
studies when he's like, I'm
going to meet with Spike.
It was just a working
environment.
Marlon Wayans was a good
friend of mine.
He was doing movies and going
to class at the same time.
So I think I needed
to see that.
It was the first lesson of
learning how to balance
everything.
RYAN VUKELICH: Yeah.
That's a lot going on at once.
And I think inspiring to see.
ERIC ROBERSON: Very much.
RYAN VUKELICH: So thanks
for sharing that.
ERIC ROBERSON: No problem.
RYAN VUKELICH: So can you talk
about how you had the deal
with Warner.
And in my mind, you were kind
of a trailblazer of
independent music.
People were doing it, but you've
been able to do it and
sustain it.
ERIC ROBERSON: I think my
career has been able to
overshadow how many
times I've been
dropped from record labels.
You know what I mean?
Or just how unsuccessful
I was.
Getting a contract signed was
on thing, but getting that
album out is a whole other
tricky monster.
And I remember having a song
on Billboard, and it's
growing, and being in school.
I remember telling my parents,
I can't make it to class.
I got a video out, and
just all these people
are grabbing me.
I literally can't make
it to class.
I can't do this.
So I took off like two years.
And then the Warner Brothers
situation didn't work out.
I went to Ireland.
An the Ireland situation
didn't work back.
And my mom was like, you're
going to go back to that
school and you are going to
get your scholarship back.
I was like, all right.
I went in there.
I literally sang to everybody
like, (SINGS) please give me
my scholarship back.
I'll get straight
A's, I promise.
And amazingly, I went back.
But it was crazy, because
I went back.
And it was like, (WHISPERS) oh,
there's that kid that had
that record deal.
Like the whispers walking
across the yard like,
(WHISPERS) oh, that's the kid
that fell off [INAUDIBLE]
video.
That was a long time ago.
I wonder if he still
got money.
So like the humbleness
of like--
it made me a better student, a
better singer, a more humble
artist, a more focused
everything, every aspect.
And I will tell you, if I had
this huge record and just took
off, I wouldn't be doing
music right now.
I wasn't talented enough
at the time.
I didn't know how to
handle everything.
So I had to go back.
And going back to school and
graduating was like the
hardest thing I've ever
done in life.
It really was.
But it was a great decision.
And even with that, I went back
to college and I started
writing songs for
other people.
I led a song on 112 and this
group called [INAUDIBLE]
Warner Brothers.
I was placing songs and
still recording.
And it just got to the point
where, for me, the deals
weren't working out.
And I had just too many
songs that just meant
too much for me.
It all started when I had
a real bad breakup.
And I just closed the studio
doors and started recording.
And those songs, I
wasn't going to
give to somebody else.
So that's how my independent
career started.
RYAN VUKELICH: That's cool.
Would you mind sharing a couple
of the song titles that
fall into that category.
ERIC ROBERSON: Yeah, there
was a whole album called
"Esoteric." And it's crazy,
because it was a healing
record for me.
So when the album came out and
there were songs like--
what is some of the song titles?
"A Newborn Child,"
which is saying I'll cry like
a newborn child, which I was
doing at the time.
When the album came out and I
would meet women that were
like, this record
is so beautiful.
I'm like, what do you mean?
It was about pain, you
horrible person.
Like, don't ever listen
to my record.
You don't understand.
But I had to realize that people
could relate to what I
was going through,
and it helped.
It helped me heal, would
help them heal.
There was a song called
"Miles Away" on it
that was really important.
And really, the record--
esoteric means only meant to be
understood by chosen few.
And that, to me,
was my career.
I wasn't trying to
change the world.
I wasn't trying to win
everybody over.
I was trying to just do
music for someone
who would feel this.
Because I always felt like my
music career and my love life
were parallel.
They always have been.
And as a song writer,
I was doing great.
I had songs for everybody
and their mother.
I was writing all these songs.
I was doing very, very well.
But was I fulfilled with
what I was doing?
I felt like I was a solo artist
writing, a lot of
times, compromising or
as a fan, missing
what was on the radio.
So I said, all right, let me
start doing what I feel like
I'm missing.
And I think that's what I'm
still doing to this day.
RYAN VUKELICH: That's great.
I mean, I'll be real with you.
I've healed from your music.
And that's how I first
got into you.
"Past Paradise," "Find a Way,"
those are songs that when you
listen to, you're like, man,
he's been through it.
Thanks.
ERIC ROBERSON: Yeah, yeah.
Make checks payable
to Eric Roberson.
Whoever, you can just
fill it out.
My father's back there.
He'll just accept the
checks and payments.
I'll tell you, I say
this respectfully.
I got a text earlier, and I
could show you for whoever
doesn't believe me.
The guy who I was talking to
who's in the industry, and
he's struggling in
his travels.
And he says, man, you
write great songs
about passing up vaginas.
And I was like, what a great
horrible compliment.
That was like amazingly
horrible.
Incredible at the same time.
But for me, I realized a long
time ago-- what I will tell
you is that the lyrics
come, and I can't
take credit for them.
They come, and then I learn
what they mean.
And then I try to be good
enough to follow them.
You know what I mean?
And that's been my
whole career.
So it's like I'll a write a song
and go, wow, this sounds
pretty good.
And then the lyrics
are stable.
And then I learn what that
song meant for me.
"Find a Way" was important
because it was--
if anyone listens to "Find a
Way," it's a song of mine.
And it's like I sing it
two parts, one high
note and one low note.
And I pan the high one all
the way to the right.
And I pan the low one all
the way to the left.
And the high one meant
to be emotion.
And the low note meant
to be reality.
And as a man, I was
battling that.
Like sometimes we meet a young
lady and we're so used to our
routine, she could be the soul
mate, but I got that game.
I got to put that game on her.
That I'm just ruining.
Like, can I stop the game
for two seconds just
to see who she is?
And I've been lucky enough to
write about it or my breakups.
I made a decision a long time
ago, when I went back to
Howard, that every subject
that came to mind or
everything.
I went through, I'll
put to music.
So every argument, every great
day, every whatever, would be
put to music.
And I lost a lot of girlfriends
that way.
It came with the good or bad.
(SWEETLY) You wrote that
for me? (ANGRILY) You
wrote that about me?
It was the same thing, literally
24 hours apart.
But it's something I
decided to do, man.
And if God to allowed me to
have certain thoughts and
lyrics and melodies, how
dare I not use them.
RYAN VUKELICH: That's
incredible.
So what's your process?
Do you just wake up with
something in your
head or does it vary?
Because I know sometimes people
would say, oh, I woke
up in the middle of the night.
Sometimes I actually sat down.
Does it change?
ERIC ROBERSON: It changes.
I'm a fisherman of creativity.
So I'm under the belief that
the idea already exists.
I just have to find it
and make it tangible.
So a lot of my records are
written in the bathroom.
I'll leave up to you to think
what's happening in the
bathroom when I'm
writing them.
But every aspect from shaving
to showering to
other S words that--
[LAUGHTER]
ERIC ROBERSON: Soaping up.
RYAN VUKELICH: Situating.
ERIC ROBERSON: Situating.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But it's funny, because before,
I was very much a
slave to creativity.
I was very much like if an idea
came and I was at the
Thanksgiving table with my
family I haven't seen all
week, I would get up right then
and go into the studio.
I was very much like, I have
an idea, and everyone must
respect the idea.
Now, I believe that it's
going to come back now.
So now having kids and having a
wife, I realize that that's
a great idea, but I'm pushing
on the swing, and he's too
young to be left here.
I mean, it'll come back.
And it comes back.
It comes back.
But I'm always writing.
Always.
My phone is full of lyrics.
And I'm always writing
letters.
And I feel like you should just
write in general to stay
in shape for when
the idea comes.
RYAN VUKELICH: Definitely.
You mentioned your kids.
Just two more questions.
One is what's one thing you
learned about yourself since
you've become a father, which
was two years ago ish?
ERIC ROBERSON: Yeah.
I have a two-year-old and a
seven-month-old, and I'm not
going to cry in front
of all these people.
The thing I learned
about myself.
Man, I don't know.
I learn about my kids.
But I learned that I can
be a morning person.
Because probably for the last 20
years, I've averaged waking
up at 12:00 to 1:00
in the afternoon.
And now my sons get up 7:30,
6:00 whatever in the morning.
But I learned it's another
level of love, man.
But it's tough, because I have
great parents who I knew the
example of incredible love.
I have amazing nephews
and nieces.
And I was crazy over them.
So I knew that it could exist
where it wasn't just more of
an a-ha moment.
But if anything, I learned that
you can balance it all.
I will tell everybody out
there, there was a guy
recently who I was just working
with who was a cameraman.
And he travels a lot.
He just got married.
He's like, my wife wants to have
a kid, but, man, I just
travel too much, man.
And I'm like, it's
going to fit.
It's going to make
its way, man.
Don't hold off for that.
I don't think we
really waited.
I didn't push it away.
But now, my last two records I
recorded, a lot of time, my
son was on my lap.
Either one of them.
You know what I mean?
Because I got to get
this idea done.
I want to spend time with him.
And he wants to spend
time with me.
Let's go in the studio.
You know what I mean?
And it just works.
It just works.
And I look forward to having
them one tour with me and the
first time they actually write
a song or something like.
I look forward to all that.
So I feel what I may learn is
just that my dreams are coming
true, more and more.
RYAN VUKELICH: Excellent.
That's wonderful.
So speaking of the studio,
last question.
What's coming up next for you?
I've heard United Tenor
is in the mix.
ERIC ROBERSON: And I'm
not going to cry
about this one either.
I have to say that first,
because if I don't
say it, I will cry.
I started doing music because
of three influences.
And one was A Tribe
Called Quest.
Number two was Stevie Wonder.
And another was a group
called Commission.
It was a gospel group from
Detroit called Commission.
[CLAPPING]
ERIC ROBERSON: Thank you.
And one of the founders of that
group was a guy named
Fred Hammond, an amazing
vocalist, amazing writer.
And not only just musically,
but I remember as a kid
hearing their music and going,
whatever that is,
I want to do that.
And I've had chances of meeting
Fred Hammond for many
years, and I passed
up every time.
And my staff and some friends
surprised me with a meeting.
I'm in a restaurant thinking
I'm about be interviewed by
Tom Joyner.
And in walks Fred Hammond.
I tried to run away.
And I was like, oh,
you got me.
You got me, man.
And just because I wanted to be
able to tell the man, like,
yo, my career means so much--
I'm not going to cry.
Here we go.
Ah, toughen up.
Toughen up.
Because of you.
You know what I'm saying?
I have this career, and I didn't
know if I was where I
needed to be at yet to
really understand.
I didn't want to just hear,
oh, that's cool, man.
Thanks a lot.
When are we going to eat?
I didn't want that
to be blown over.
So we kept in touch.
And then a couple of months ago,
he said, I got an idea.
I want to form a new group.
And I would love for you to
be a member of the group.
And I was like, OK.
I mean, I'll play the piccolo
on an album for Fred.
I'll pay to do it.
And it's not just me and him.
It's Dave Hollister from
the group Blackstreet.
An amazing solo artist.
I'm a huge fan of Dave.
And another amazing artist named
Brian Courtney Wilson
who I'm friends with already.
I met him years ago, and
we kept in touch.
And we all went to Dallas.
And over the last month or so,
we travelled back and forth,
and we recorded an
incredible album.
And so the group's called
United Tenors or UT.
The album comes out
March 26th.
We had our first concert
last Saturday.
We shot a music video
and live performance
for a crowd in Dallas.
And we cried through
the whole show.
All four are just literally--
it's a dream come true, really,
in every aspect.
We performed four songs and we
played the rest of the record.
So while we're singing,
we're crying.
While we're playing
the records for
people, we're crying.
Someone said something amazing
on stage, so literally, when
you see the video, we're all
like this with just towels on
our face through the
whole performance.
But it's tears of joy.
And we're probably not going to
stop crying anytime soon.
In all honesty, 10, 20 shows
we're still going to be just
like, (FAKE SOBBING) I just so
appreciate this opportunity.
And it's a gospel album, man.
I pride myself on it.
I never hid the fact that
I'm a Christian.
And I feel there's been a
ministry in all of my music.
So it's really cool to be doing
a gospel album and with
two of my heroes and a very good
friend of mine as well.
RYAN VUKELICH: Yeah,
that's incredible.
Thanks for sharing that.
ERIC ROBERSON: Thank you.
RYAN VUKELICH: I'm really
honored to have you all here
today too. to the point where
I might cry with you.
ERIC ROBERSON: To
tears of joy.
Everybody, everybody, pass
the tissues out.
RYAN VUKELICH: So Eric, thanks
so much for being here.
I'm looking forward
to tonight.
ERIC ROBERSON: Ryan, always
a pleasure, man.
Always.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]